foreign
hey you guys Merry Christmas happy
holidays and all that jazz and this is
the Christmas sort of edition of the
movie retrospective
so I probably mentioned it before um
actually I know I've mentioned it before
several times but I love horror
anthologies of all kinds and I have a
particular soft spot in my heart for the
British what they call the portmanteau
films that were released by Amicus
Productions back in the 1960s and 1970s
so because it's Christmas I decided to
talk about a movie that isn't entirely
based around Christmas per se but does
actually have one segment that's set on
Christmas Eve and features kind of like
a killer Santa so I figured like it kind
of counts like as a Christmas movie so
I'm talking of course about the 1972
film Tales from the Crypt
now this was a five segment Anthology
movie directed by Freddie Francis who
had done a couple of Amicus uh
anthologies before he did uh Dr terror's
House of Horrors from 1965. he did
torture Garden from 1967.
um incidentally he's actually like he
directed a lot of stuff but he's better
known as a cinematographer and he
actually worked on some really like
classic movies like the Innocence from
1961 you know the based on the turn of
the screw that was a adaptation to turn
of the screw and he worked with David
Lynch like he worked on three David
Lynch movies Elephant Man uh Dune and
the straight story and uh he directed a
couple of hammer films too uh including
the evil of Frankenstein from 1964 and
Dracula has risen from the grave for
1968 so you know the guys like got a
really good resume so Amicus Productions
I kind of feel like you know they're
kind of known for their Anthology films
even though I think in total they only
made Seven they made like some other
films as well that were just like all
one story like the skull and stuff but
the thing about it is in spite of being
based in London based around shepparton
Studios and being kind of like heavily
associated with the UK obviously uh the
company was actually founded by two
Americans who were producers and
screenwriters uh Milton subotsky and Max
Rosenberg now Milton suboski in
particular was a big fan of EC Comics
you know like the American you know
there were William Gaines Comics they
had did all different kinds but um you
know they did kind of the horror ones
which is the ones that we're talking
about like in particular so uh subotsky
was actually able to sell his partner
Max Rosenberg on purchasing the rights
to the various horror comics series that
EC had done like Tales from the Crypt
the Vault of horror and the haunt of
fear and they decided they were going to
adapt some of these stories into an
anthology film and they actually ended
up doing a couple more subsequently
after the success of this one
now I'm probably I'm sure that probably
most people particularly like maybe
younger people or people my generation
and younger
um they're probably more familiar with
the very iconic HBO Tales from the Crypt
series like from the 1990s I think it
started in 1989 but like it went into
the 90s
um but in spite of that this 1972 film
was as far as I'm aware uh the first
time that any of the stories from the EC
Comics had been adapted to the big
screen or the small screen for that
matter like I said I'm not entirely sure
if that's the case but I'm pretty sure
it is now even though the finished film
in 1972 was called Tales from the Crypt
um only two of the featured stories in
the movie were taken from that
particular comic two of the other ones
in the movie were taken from the haunt
of fear and the remaining one was
actually sourced From the Vault of
horror so first up after uh box tokata
and Fugue plays on the [ __ ] uh we have
the start of the wraparound story so
we're actually following a tour group
that's flooring like some creepy
catacombs I think they actually shot
this in Highgate Cemetery in London if
I'm not mistaken now even though the
guide tells you know very specifically
like tells everybody to stay together
and not lag behind uh five very
inattentive [ __ ] or people who
just don't give a [ __ ] I guess wander
off on their own anyway and they soon
find themselves in this kind of Spooky
Little Crypt Grotto type situation and
it has like a little Stone seat with
like a big skull and the carved in the
wall and [ __ ] like that
now once they're inside and then like
the kind of door seals behind them they
can't get out
a man in sort of like a monk looking get
up uh suddenly appears so this is the
Crypt Keeper and in this iteration he's
played by the legendary stage actor sir
Ralph Richardson who was also in another
movie that I discussed uh recently on my
flickers of fear series which was
whoever slew Auntie Rue which is another
Christmas horror movie
so they all come in there the Crypt
Keeper basically tells him hey I'll sit
down and like zip your lips um I'm gonna
like tell you some [ __ ]
you know like that I know some stuff
about you so then we delve into the
stories proper so the first segment
which is the Christmas one uh is called
and all through the house and it was
taken from a story in the Vault of
horror number 35 uh which came out in
1954. and again set on Christmas Eve
so you have a woman named Joanne who's
actually played by Joan Collins and very
near the beginning of the story she
quite coldly like sneaks up behind her
husband while he's reading the paper and
essentially just like Shanks the
[ __ ] they don't really show like
how they do it she did it with the poker
so I guess she like hit him on the hat
or something like that but they don't
like actually show it
um so this kills him instantly and uh
also has the added side effect of
getting red temper paint all over the
white shag rug yeah this has got that
like super fake looking blood uh so it
turns out that she bumped off the old
man for his life insurance policy so
she's gonna have to make the whole thing
look like an accident she probably
should have planned this [ __ ] better
though because not only is her daughter
Carol who's actually played by Chloe
Franks who was also in whoever slew
Annie Roo like that movie that I just
talked about uh so the daughter is
upstairs and she's actually supposed to
be sleeping but she's still awake
because of course it's Christmas Eve and
she's super excited about Santa coming
but apparently Joanne's whole plan which
you realize as you know things start to
unfold was she wanted to make it look
like her husband fell down the basement
stairs and was like busted his skull
open presumably which makes me wonder
like why didn't she just lure him to the
basement steps and shove him down anyway
like rather than killing him in the
living room getting blood all over the
carpet and the fireplace poker which she
then has to clean up and then having to
like haul his big ass over to the
basement stairs anyway it just seems
like you know it's I'm not an expert in
spouse killing or anything like that I'm
just kind of like throwing out some
constructive criticism I'm just saying I
would have gone about things a little
bit differently that's all I'm saying so
while Joanne starts cleaning up the
scene uh the very eerie like Christmas
carols that she's been listening to on
the radio because again Christmas Eve uh
it's interrupted by a News Bulletin now
it turns out that a dangerous lunatic
has escaped from a nearby Asylum and is
now running around loose in the area
dressed in a Santa suit now to her
credit Joanne does immediately take this
threat seriously like she's like oh [ __ ]
and she goes and like locks all the
doors and windows and pulls all the
curtains closed which again she probably
should have done before if she was gonna
be killing her husband that evening and
all and wouldn't you know it but the
crazy murderer Santa does actually show
up at the house kind of leering in
through the windows and like trying to
get inside now Joanne actually starts to
call the cops but then she's like oh
[ __ ] that's right I haven't finished
cleaning up the murder scene to make it
look like an accident yet so probably I
should refrain from calling the cops
until like that deed is done you know
what I mean so after she's done cleaning
everything up um you know she kind of
like dumps her husband's body down the
basement stairs in a stunt that actually
looked like somebody could have broke
their neck so Props to the stunt guy for
doing that because I was like holy [ __ ]
yeah it looks really painful so she
pushes him down the stairs and then very
artfully like drips Blood on the side of
his head and on the floor and everything
like that and I'm just like I think
you're overthinking it it's like you
know what I mean uh so but she looks
around she's very sad slide with their
handiwork yeah that totally looks like
an accident this is I'm I'm gonna get
away with this [ __ ]
so then she goes upstairs to like check
on her daughter but her daughter is no
longer in bed
so obviously she's frantic like where
the hell did this kid go did she see
what I just did or anything like that so
she runs back downstairs looking for the
kid uh only to find that Carol the
daughter has let the maniac inside
believing that he's the real Santa Claus
even though I mean he looks like kind of
like a homeless drunk but you know what
I mean this she's a kid she doesn't know
so uh the lunatic in the Santa suit then
proceeds to essentially like strangle
Joanne to death as Christmas music plays
spookily in the background so this was
actually a very very short but uh still
a really effective story it's actually
told with very very little dialogue I
mean the dialogue is very very minimal
but it's still like really creepy and
it's like pretty compelling and the the
Christmas music like The Christmas Carol
is going on in the background give it
this really like unsettling Vibe because
you know it's like this pretty Christmas
music that's playing while Joanna is
like very dispassionately like
cleaning up the murder scene like
because she's just very like Boop like
you're dead and then she's like yep
scrubbing up the blood and like all this
other kind of stuff just like she
doesn't give a [ __ ] at all
um but yeah so that's really creepy and
then like the whole tension about like
the killer Santa like lurking around
outside
um as I mentioned the blood looks fake
as [ __ ] but you know that's kind of par
for the course for movies from this era
so it didn't really bother me all that
much it is a little distracting because
it's very very clear that it's tempera
paint
um and it's because of this consistency
in the color and everything like that
but I've seen like other movies like
that from this era and that's just what
they did they didn't figure out like how
to darken it until later on now this
same story incidentally was adapted
again for the later HBO series in the
90s actually this one was from season
one I think so it was 1989 and it
follows pretty much the same plot beats
although interestingly the later one
only implied that the killer Santa was
gonna murder like the main lady like it
ended when she was still standing there
on the staircase screaming like oh my
God my daughter brought in the the Santa
whereas the version from 1972 actually
showed Santa like strangling Joanne in
front of the fireplace it didn't show or
die but he's basically like ah she's
like you know what I mean so it's it
just showed more which I thought was
like kind of interesting so the second
story in the Anthology was also another
short one uh reflection of death and
this was taken from Tales from the Crypt
number 23 from 1951. so in this story
we're introduced to like a kind of
shitty dude named Carl who's played by
Ian Hendry
and he tells his wife and kids that he's
going on a business trip but he's
actually running off with his mistress
Susan who's played by Angela Grant and
he's never planning on returning while
the love birds are like driving along a
road that night very excited about you
know going to their new Flats starting
their new life together yada yada they
get into an accident after like swerving
to avoid a truck that's like drifted
into their Lane
now after the accident it seems as
though Carl is alive and like was thrown
clear of the vehicle but we're not
entirely sure what happened to Susan or
how bad Carl's injuries are because
we're suddenly seeing everything from
Carl's point of view
so as he starts like lumbering around
presumably like looking for help a few
people see him and like flee from him in
Terror so you can probably guess kind of
where this story is going so Carl makes
his way back to the home of his wife and
family and kind of like peeks in the
window only to observe that his wife is
being consoled by another man that
appears to be her husband and I was like
damn she moved on quick whatever either
that or I think what he thinks is that
oh I went away on the business trip and
she immediately like had some other dude
come over so Carl like knocks on the
door but when his wife answers she
freaks the hell out like at the sight of
him and then just like slams the door in
his face and he's just like huh okay
that's a little weird so obviously he's
very confused uh so he next goes to
Susan's apartment now Susan herself
answers the door and she looks like
pretty okay I mean she looks like she
got through the accident presumably like
unscathed she also doesn't react to Carl
with horror as everybody has so far but
we soon realized that this is because
she's actually blind and yes you guessed
it she was blinded in the accident but
spoiler alert Carl was killed and not
only that but it happened to God damn
years ago so he's I don't know if he's
been wandering around for two years or
if it just like two years for him to dig
out of his grave or what but it's been
two years
um so yeah he's in the apartment
and Susan said uh hey you died two years
ago what what are you doing here like
you know what I mean she seems like
pretty calm all things considered
um I think she doesn't know that it's
him she's like Carl died two years ago
so because she can't see him like I said
uh so actually Carl looks down and sees
his like zombie-like Visage kind of like
reflected in this mirror-topped coffee
table that she has and he has like just
a total meltdown and at that point he
actually like snaps awake in the
passenger seat of the car like driving
with Susan toward their new life or
whatever like back at the beginning of
the story so like it was all a dream but
then he tells her oh my God I had the
worst [ __ ] dream and then the
accident like that started this whole
chain of events like happens again like
for real so it's almost kind of like the
previous story had all been a
premonition so this was a pretty good
yarn as well um even though it's pretty
obvious like as soon as the accident
happens like what the outcome is gonna
be you know what I mean um it's still
entertaining though and the fact that
it's so short means that it kind of like
gets in and out without dawdling and
that gives it like a lot more impact
even though like I said you can pretty
much tell where it's gonna go so the
third story is called Poetic Justice and
this one is notable for featuring the
awesome Peter Cushing in a very very
like emotionally heartbreaking role he's
kind of playing a lovable widower who
sort of like um is the target of two
snotty [ __ ] so this story actually
originally appeared in the haunted fear
comic uh number 12 from 1952. so you got
to kind of status conscious upper class
twits James Elliott and his dad Edward
uh who are played by Robin Phillips and
David Markham respectively
and they live in this sort of kind of
swanky neighborhood doing Swanky man
things you know
so there's something about the
neighborhood that kind of sticks in
their crawl though and that is the
shabbily dressed person of Arthur
grimsdyke who is played by Peter Cushing
as I mentioned who is an elderly like
garbage man
and he lives across the street
now although Mr grimsdike is a
delightful delightful human being uh who
is just adored by all the neighborhood
children and you know has a particular
fondness for caring for stray dogs
because he has like a bunch of dogs uh
the snobby [ __ ] across the street
think that his kind of shabby looking
appearance and his sort of rundown a
little bit house are lowering everyone's
property values
now Mr grimsych doesn't want to move
even though the neighborhood is kind of
like gentrified around him I guess they
imply because he shared this house with
his wife for many years and he still
feels her presence there and kind of
like cherishes the memories that they
made together in this house he's also
they note a believer in spiritualism and
he talks to his dead wife regularly like
using this kind of like little cardboard
Ouija board type situation like asking
her for advice and the thing about it
these scenes are actually like pretty
sad like to watch because if you know
anything about Peter Cushing
um he actually had a really hard time
like dealing with the loss of his own
wife like in real life so you can really
tell that he put a lot of his own
experience into this role and you know
it's pretty sad it's like pretty sad to
watch it so because the two snotty
neighbors especially the sun like more
of the Sun than the dad
um since they're both petty little
[ __ ] they decide that they're going
to essentially like conduct a campaign
of Terror against this poor old man in
order to drive him out of the
neighborhood
so they do [ __ ] like they tear up
another neighbor's prize roses and blame
Grim grimsticks dogs
um you know which kind of like brings
down animal control and they come and
confiscate all the dogs which is
terrible
um they actually engineer it so that he
loses his job and because he's only two
years from retiring like he ends up
losing his pension as well so they're
trying to like also drive him into
poverty which nice then they start like
a whisper campaign that he's basically a
pedophile like they don't state that
explicitly but it's very very heavily
implied that that's what they mean and
that actually like causes all the
parents to forbid their children from
visiting him because like it used to be
the kids would go visit him and he would
do like little puppet shows and play
games with them and stuff like that and
now everybody thinks he's a perv so I
know the kids will come visit him
anymore and he doesn't really know why I
mean it's pretty diabolical all around
like what this [ __ ] [ __ ] does so
poor all Mr grimsych is not really sure
like why life is [ __ ] on him so
copiously all of a sudden because he
doesn't know about the dorks across the
street but he does kind of try and
maintain his positive attitude because
he is like a very like upbeat kind of
happy dude
um and he kind of like talks to his
deceased wife to make himself feel
better
so the neighbor James is mad that all of
these plots that he's been trying to
cook up haven't really resulted in
grimsek moving away so he decides on
another scheme so since Valentine's Day
is right around the corner James writes
out like a [ __ ] ton of Valentine's Day
cards and they all contain these really
hateful like verses and poems in there
about pretty much how everyone wishes
that Grim's Dyke would just like [ __ ]
off and go away you know what I mean and
then he fakes it so that it looks like
the cards come from everyone in the
neighborhood like everybody in the
neighborhood sent him one saying you
suck you know what I mean
um now apparently this is the last straw
for Grim's day I mean he can't stand
he's just a nice old man and he can't
stand the thought of everyone despising
him and sadly he ends up hanging himself
so we then jump ahead a year uh it's
Valentine's Day again and James seems to
be feeling a little bit guilty about
that whole driving harmless old man to
suicide thing that he pulled last year a
little late to be worried about it now
bud uh but guilty or not uh since this
is an easy comic story obviously you
just know that this douchebag is gonna
get his deserved comeuppance uh and you
in due course grimsdyke digs his way out
of his own grave and shuffles on over to
James's house where he ends up tearing
out the fucker's heart and leaving it
wrapped up in like a valentine poem that
he wrote in the motherfucker's blood
which you know good riddance I mean he
had that coming gonna say I'm gonna say
too that I think the makers of My Bloody
Valentine saw this movie for sure
because the closing scene of this like
where his dad comes out of his like this
bloody poem and then he opens back the
paper and then there's like the heart is
in there I mean that's very much like a
scene from My Bloody Valentine from
1981. so this was another really solid
Story I mean Peter Cushing like I said
is really affecting in it I mean you
just feel so [ __ ] bad for him because
he just seems like such a sweet old man
and this chode across the street is just
being the literal worst like for the
most pointless of reasons because it's
like oh well his house looks a little
bit shabby or he looks a little bit
shabby and blah blah and it's like we're
gonna do all this horrible I mean I
can't imagine
um I have to say I think this was
probably the goriest like of all the
segments
um you know what with the torn out heart
and all that which I mean it's not that
graphic by modern standards but it was
still like pretty rough for like a PG
movie like you know even from back then
uh I have to say too that the undead
Peter Cushing makeup was also pretty
great um especially because you rarely
get to see Peter Cushing as a zombie so
I thought that was like pretty cool and
I liked the I particularly like the
teeth they put on them I don't know why
but he looks like pretty creepy and I
thought it was pretty cool so the fourth
story wish you were here is basically a
riff on the classic you know WWE Jacob's
Tale the monkey's paw which I think we
probably all read in school and uh this
variation of the tale appeared in the
haunt of fear number 22 from 1953. so it
centers around a businessman named Ralph
who's played by Richard green
and he's going bankrupt because
apparently of some like nefarious
dealings he's been up to
so his lawyer financial advisor whatever
um tells him well you better start
selling off some [ __ ] because uh you're
broke but I mean from the looks of it I
think he'll be just fine I mean he's got
a mansion that's like stuffed with
expensive antiques he's got a sweet
sports car that would probably bring in
a pretty penny if he sold that I mean
you know the thing it's like rich people
bankruptcy it's not the same as poor
people bankruptcy you know the kind
where you actually have zero dollars and
zero assets it's like oh I'm so poor I
have this huge mansion and a sports car
and all these antiques that are worth
millions of dollars boohoo you know what
I mean I was just kind of like yeah Cry
Me a River [ __ ] so while Ralph
and his wife Enid he's played by Barbara
Murray they're at home like mooning over
all of these beautiful possessions that
they now have to sell because they don't
have any money left you know relatively
um Enid suddenly sees a previously
unnoticed inscription like on the base
of this Chinese statue that they have so
it's basically a similar setup to the
monkey's paw where the thing grants
three wishes but it also warns you like
be careful what you wish for and how you
go about wishing for it because the
wording of it is like really really
important it'll pretty much take
everything like as literally as possible
or it'll like figure out a way to [ __ ]
you over somehow like while giving you
what you want at the same time just like
in the monkey's paw so they don't really
believe it but they figure what the hell
you know what I mean so Enid actually
like you know grabs the thing and wishes
for a lot of money even though I will
know that in the universe of this
segment of this story both Ralph and
Enid the characters have read the
monkey's paw and remember what happened
in it despite this they go ahead and do
this [ __ ] anyway I guess because they're
desperate but also because they're kind
of idiots so much like in the original
story the money does appear as promised
but in the form of a life insurance pay
payout after Ralph is killed in a car
crash now in the original story the
couple actually got the money after
their son got killed in an industrial
accident at work I think he got trapped
in the Machinery or something like that
so Ralph's car crash uh actually
happened because Ralph was speeding as
he tried to get away from this guy on a
motorcycle behind him that had like a
skull face you know what I mean so it
was kind of like it was kind of implying
that there was like some Supernatural
Shenanigans like hey I gotta kill you
we're like you know what I mean then
like he crashed the car so the very
distraught Enid is now a rich woman but
instead of just shrugging her shoulders
and accepting the win being like Oh well
he's dead at least I have all this money
she makes the very stupid second wish
that Ralph could be back to the way he
was just before the accident so like I
said she tries to be really careful with
her wording like because not only did
she see what happened with the first
wish but she's also read the story the
monkey's paw that like I said the the
wish like the way you word it it tries
to like [ __ ] you over but in this case
the Chinese figurine slash monkey's paw
is still cleverer than she is which not
a high bar to clear gonna say uh so she
wishes for him to be back the way he was
before the accident so a bunch of
pallbearers like bring in Ralph's body
in a coffin like into the house
so they opened the coffin and he's dead
obviously but there's not a scratch on
him and that's because they discovered
that the accident didn't actually kill
him he actually had a heart attack from
Fright because remember skeleton dude on
the motorcycle before his car wrecked
thus the magical statue did as Enid
asked exactly and restored him to the
state he was just before the accident
stone cold dead from Fright so at this
point the lawyer financial advisor guy
whose name is Charles if I didn't
mention that he very wisely tells Enid
to like quit it with the wishing like
while she's ahead um and just let the
dude rest in peace and she's still got
all the money but Enid is just like
beside herself and makes the absolutely
stupidest wish of all
had she stopped now yeah her husband
would be dead but she's a lot of them
all the money but no she doesn't do that
she wishes that Ralph would be restored
to life and further she goes on and says
and that he'll live forever which I was
like ah so close why did you have to say
that
so Ralph comes back to life all right
but the poor bastard he's dead he's been
embalmed and the embalming fluid in his
veins is thus causing him unendurable
Agony uh Enid is horrified obviously at
what she's done I'm like you dumb [ __ ]
why why did you say that so she like
actually attempts to put him out of his
misery like chopping off some of his
limbs in the process like his hands and
stuff but because she wished for him to
live forever he can't die now so now
he's gonna spend the rest of Eternity
presumably in excruciating pain so I'm
just like Goodwin Enid I'm sure he's
really gonna appreciate that [ __ ] so
this story as well was sort of adapted
again on the later HBO series but it was
actually called last respect
um it actually went back to using the
actual monkey's paw instead of the
Chinese statue and it made the wishing
protagonist like three feuding sisters
like rather than a married couple so not
really all that similar now that I think
about it but kind of similar so the
final story blind alleys is also the
longest by quite a large margin and was
taken from Tales from the Crypt number
46 uh from 1955.
so in this story there's kind of like an
authoritarian type military dude named
Major William Rogers who's played by
Nigel Patrick
and he gets a new job as the Director of
a home for the Blind and it's all men so
I guess it's just like a men's home for
the blind or whatever
now right from the start this this
[ __ ] is a hard ass like he's
trying to save money by turning off the
heat like in the dorms at night
rationing out the blankets like giving
the mostly elderly residents just watery
gruel to eat instead of real food like
he's not giving them any meat or
anything and uh you know as if that
wasn't bad enough like while the blind
residents are all like suffering uh the
major himself of course is living kind
of high on the hog I mean he decorates
his office with these really expensive
paintings like he drinks like really
pricey wine like he's eating really nice
meals like on these china dishes you
know what I mean it's that type of [ __ ]
so one of the residents whose name is
George Carter and he's actually played
by Patrick McGee from A Clockwork Orange
among many other things uh he actually
tries to reason with the major but uh
the director is not sympathetic and he
even threatens to sick his trained
German Shepherd Shane on the men uh if
they piss and moan too much now after
one of the Blind Men actually freezes to
death like one night in the dorm because
no heat and no blankets remember George
and the others decide that's the straw
that broke the camel's back and they're
gonna band together and take a very very
elaborate revenge on the major
so what they do and it takes a while for
this to play out and I wasn't entirely
I'd seen this movie before but I didn't
remember like what it was that they were
doing you know what I mean and it takes
a while before you figure it out
so basically they have this thing where
the first thing they do is lure his dog
away like using meat for like or little
meat scraps or whatever like for
leftover from their lunches because they
need the dog because otherwise he'll
stick the dog on them like I said so he
they lure the dog away and then they
lock it in this chamber like down in the
basement and then they're all able to
kind of like just through strength of
numbers they're able to go back and
subdue the major himself because he's
kind of like a weenie when he doesn't
have his dog like to [ __ ] you know
front Forum so they kind of overcome him
and they put him in like a separate cell
in the basement like you can hear the
dog barking but he can't like get to him
meanwhile the Blind Men very
systematically like construct this sort
of like hallway trap kind of situation
and it has like all of these razor
blades like sticking out of the walls
like at certain points now after a
couple of days I guess it's like two or
three days they actually let the major
out but he finds himself like he's like
what the [ __ ] like it's all like closed
in you know what I mean because they
built this whole thing around it so he
kind of finds him so there's only one
way for him to go so he's like herded
down this hallway and he just narrowly
avoids getting sliced to ribbons with
the blades because the walls are like
really close together and there's all
these little blades sticking out
unbeknownst to him though at the other
end of the hallway his dog has been
trapped in that small cell without any
food for the same amount of time like so
it's been several days since the dog's
eaten
so when the Blind Man released the dog
and then they turn out the lights too so
that like the major can't see anything
so suffice it to say that the major is
either a and uh and or gonna get uh
sliced up by razors and eaten by his own
dog uh pretty much no matter what he
does and you know again good riddance he
really had that coming because he was a
gigantic [ __ ] and this was also a
pretty damn good story it went on a
little bit too long for my taste uh
especially in contrast with the other
stories which are all like pretty short
but I mean I actually didn't mind it too
much because the majors fate like when
he finally you know when it finally
happened was so delicious and the fact
that it was so prolonged I think like
made the payoff a lot more effective
um you know and it's always nice to see
Patrick McGee in something uh and really
in this one he's like at his Patrick
McGee East like in this as well that's
always a big plus because he's I love
him he's such a great actor so this
story blind alleys was also adapted
again for the later HBO series
um even though the title was actually
change to revenge is the nuts and the
main protagonist was changed to a blind
woman it was set in a School for the
Blind but there were women at it too and
she was a blind woman and she was
actually raped by the director like
among other indignities uh so the story
is similar to the original in other
respects but they did change that aspect
of it so after all five stories have
played out and in case I didn't mention
it like the five people in the Crypt at
the beginning of the movie were all the
main characters like in the subsequent
segments uh it's then revealed to no
one's surprise that the Crypt Keeper is
actually just showing these [ __ ]
like their misdeeds before sending them
off to hell like this is why you're
going to hell because of this [ __ ] that
you did so Hal is like right outside the
stone door of this cribs because one of
them opens it and they're like ah then
they fall down in like a really bad
Optical effect like into the fiery pit
down below
um so yeah so while it's pretty easy to
see this twist coming like you know
these people are all already dead or
they're in purgatory or whatever
um it's still fun although I have to
admit admit
that I did wonder why it was the
character of Ralph in the wish you were
here segment that ended up in the
hellcrypt for one thing
um it seemed like he didn't do anything
like all that terrible like he didn't
kill anybody or anything like some of
the other people did really the worst
thing he did as far as I could determine
was that there was like a hint that some
shady business dealings had been the
cause of his bankruptcy but which is bad
but it's not that bad not like murdering
people like most of the other people did
and for another thing I have to note in
the context of his story that he was in
he actually couldn't die because the
wife had wished for him to live forever
so what what is he even doing here like
he's an eternal being now so he
shouldn't even be in this [ __ ]
um you know I don't know whatever I'm
just overthinking the whole thing that's
kind of what I do so sorry so yeah I
mean although this version of Tales from
the Crypt it's pretty restrained like
especially in comparison to even the
original comic books which were actually
like pretty gory and you know obviously
the much more flamboyant and like much
gorier and much funnier like HBO series
um you know and not to mention you know
obviously Creep Show uh you know from
the 1980s 80s which was I guess EC
Comics adjacent it wasn't like
specifically based on an EC comic
stories it was all like original stories
that were in the spirit of EC Comics
um and that was kind of like more like
the original Comics so this movie is
very like is based on stories from that
but it's a lot more subdued than those
stories would be like it's not quite as
gory it's not I mean you know it's
British and it's like from the 1970s but
it's still a really enjoyable flick if
you like British movies from this era
and it's it's a pretty damn good
Anthology like one of the better ones
um and like I said since it's Christmas
today it's uh you know cats as a
Christmas movie and also kind of counts
as a Valentine's Day movie if you want
to get technical so it has that going
for it um you know but whatever holiday
you watching for uh get you know give it
a look if you've never seen it and you
like Anthology movies or if you've seen
it like let me know what you thought
about it in the comments and then I'll
do it for this retrospective merry
Christmas happy holidays and I'll see
you guys again on the next one bye
thank you